my character dies horribly on the street
[Music]
so basically my character dies
horribly in the street of a stabbing
okay after doing her best to tell
sydney please we need to go he's going
to get us we need to run we need to get
away
stupid people go back smart people run
we're smart people so we need to get out
of here
but she wants to go back i end up
stabbed
oh wow hopefully being in more sequels
that's what that's what
elise thinks but you know um
we never really got into depth of what
her job was what her goals were you know
we were in college
and you know who knows maybe she was
definitely a badass and had a lot of
you know husbands so who knows what she
would have been doing but it would have
been great to be alive
[Music]
i don't remember really honestly no but
most craft services when it's been a hit
movie is just
ridiculously dope with lobster
and all types of treats and all types of
delicious things that we're not supposed
to eat to look as cute as we are in our
outfits it's usually a lot of great
stuff that you're not supposed to eat